remember that uh this is a program that
really wouldn't exist without your
support and the primary
source of that support comes through
website memberships you can read
all about it and sign up in under a
minute at
joinpacman.com do have a really great
discussion forum with more than i think
we're close to 22 or 23
000 of our viewers are subscribed to our
subreddit you can find it at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit there are a number of
interesting posts from our viewers a
couple of which i want to highlight
one user who goes by the
name stressed matt said would the
cutting of the postal service hurt
republicans
we know that democrats are more likely
to vote absentee while republicans are
more likely to vote in person but
republicans are more likely to live in
rural areas rural areas are the
ones are the areas that actually need a
functioning postal service the most
so given the delays would it be more
likely for a rural voter to not have
their ballot delivered on time
compared to someone in a city well you
have to compare that which i'm sure
you're right about
you have to compare that to the
disproportionate number of biden
supporters planning to vote by mail and
that already accounts for the urban
rural divide so it's it's ultimately a
math problem
my instinct my instinct is that
still accounting for the urban rural
divide
it is still joe biden who's worse off if
the postal service
fails to deliver um absentee ballots
that's my
instinct uh but ultimately it is an
empirical question
with some unknowns and we'd have to
think about whether we can actually
gather all the data we need to answer
that another post
from the subreddit by user kmlo17
who says can we all just take a moment
to recognize the fact
that david is now less than ten thousand
subscribers shy of one million
uh it is not even ten thousand in fact
let me take a look while we're while
we're talking here
we are now only 7 000 subscribers shy
of 1 million on youtube it's actually
looking like we're going to hit the
million during our vacation week which
you know if five years ago you said uh
you're going to hit a million
subscribers in 2020 but you'll be on
vacation
i would have said there's no way you
could know that and it does look like
that's the way it's going to be
but we've got some great videos and a
bunch of great congratulatory messages
from
some of our friends many of whom you
will recognize plan for when we do hit 1
million subscribers so yes we are only
7 000 subscribers away help us
once we get to a million i think things
are going to get very very crazy
in in a number of different ways
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
and of course
join the discussion on the david pakman
show subreddit
at davidpakman.com r-e-d-d-i-t